at least one person is dead dozens more
injured after a las vegas-based tour bus
crashed in the state of arizona now we
told you this happened about noon as the
bus was
in route to grand canyon west orco mano
went right to the scene of the crash
tonight
has much more on what we know about the
victims
authorities say the deadly tour bus
crash happened here on this stretch of
diamond bar road
as the bus was headed toward grand
canyon west this
mile marker sign ripped from the ground
this is a photo showing the aftermath of
the crash according to the mohave county
sheriff's office
the tour bus which is managed by a las
vegas-based company
was carrying at least 48 people
including the driver
when it rolled over and landed on its
side one person died at the scene and
two others were critically injured
kingman regional medical center tells us
a total of 44 people were brought to
their facility
two were treated and transported
elsewhere three had serious injuries and
the rest sustained minor injuries
the identities of those involved have
not been released yet
the mojave county sheriff's office says
the investigation into what happened
is still ongoing so stay with us for
updates reporting in medview arizona
orca mana 8 news now